(pleasant music)
- Meredith, how are you doing really?
(Meredith sighs)
- Conflicted.
There's been a lot of
stuff going on lately,
whether it's career stuff,
lots of frustration around that,
you know, being an employee
where you don't feel
as valued being on the front lines.
So it's kinda hard to deal with.
And I've been in contact with my dad
who I considered dead
to me three years ago,
and it's been a lot.
So how am I?
I'm okay sometimes, but I
could use a good cry or two.
- Yeah.
What causes you guys to reconnect?
- He went to rehab and,
'cause he was on meth,
doing a lot of drugs.
And his ex told us that
he had been doing that,
he'd been getting better.
And when they last spoke, he
said that my dad told him,
he knew he could have been a
better father to us growing up.
And it just...
I needed to hear that.
- Yeah.
- He doesn't apologize, but in that way,
that was him apologizing.
- I'm glad to hear that you
got to hear that from him
after all these years.
- Yeah, not many people get closure,
but--
- Yeah.
- Thank you for listening.
- Yeah. Thank you for sharing.
- What's in your mind?
- Right now?
I've been recently unemployed,
so I'm a little overwhelmed
with what I'm gonna do next.
- You know, it's funny
that you should say that,
'cause I feel the same way.
I still have no idea what I wanna do.
I'm happy that I have a job,
but it's not something that I wanna do,
you know, I still gotta
find my passion, my truth.
- There's a little, I
guess, comfort to know that
I'm not the only one going through it.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I'm sad that
we're all going through it.
Makes me feel less lonely, I guess.
How old are you?
- I'm 31.
- I am about to be 30, I'm 29.
I mean, we're both still young.
- Yeah, I know.
Hopefully we'll get there.
But, you know, be positive
and all that, you know,
can only, once again, take you so far,
but we gotta do what we gotta do.
- Yeah.
- What is the most romantic
thing that's happened to you?
- The most romantic?
I think I can think of one.
I actually got picked up from therapy.
Super romantic.
Had bawled my eyes out for like an hour
and got picked up with
some of my favorite food.
And we went to like a park at the beach
that I had never been to.
And we just ate and played catch
with this thing called an Aerobie.
I was freezing.
And usually, I can't deal
with the cold very well.
But I remember just
thinking to myself how,
like the cold didn't bother me.
So I think maybe that,
maybe that time.
- And you said therapy?
- Yeah.
Do you go to therapy?
- I used to.
I mean, I use it when I know I need it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, my mental health stuff
started coming up since
I was like 12 or 13.
So, been there, done that.
Do you mind me asking like,
do you have any diagnosises?
Or is it just for talking to someone?
- I've struggled with depression
since I was super young, like eight.
So I guess that would be
my official diagnosis.
- Okay.
Are you on antidepressants or anything?
- No, I haven't been for a while.
I haven't enjoyed the ones that I took
for how they make me feel.
So, been trying to do it other ways,
doing it naturopathically
or with exercise and sleep
and just taking care of myself.
- Good for you.
Good for you.
- What about you?
- Oh, yeah.
- Wanna answer both questions?
- I forgot the list.
I forgot what the original question was.
- But you wanna answer the
mental health question first?
- Oh, God, where do I start?
Major depressive disorder, anxiety, PTSD.
Anxiety is getting better, thankfully.
Now my doctors are on the track of ADHD.
I've got diabetes, Hashimoto's.
My health is all like, all over the place.
If it weren't for some of my meds,
I'd be practically a
puddle of mush, again.
I couldn't function for a long time, so.
- I'm glad to hear that
they're working for you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- That's a big blessing, I'm sure.
- Yeah, I felt like I
lost six years of my life.
But now it's definitely catching up.
I'm enjoying it.
- That's great.
The other question I think was
whenever you felt most
romanced in your life?
- Oh.
And I'm sorry, I love you.
That's my, my fiance's over (laughs)
We've all dated.
Okay, one that comes to mind.
First date, I meet this
guy at a coffee shop,
and after that, he takes me to his plane.
And yes, I said his plane.
And he flew us from
Albuquerque to Santa Fe.
- Wow.
- And from Santa Fe,
I was able, he taught
me how to fly a plane.
And it's like, you know, one
of those like little ones,
you can only seat like two people.
But not every day you
get to say, oh, yeah,
yeah, he took me on a plane
and taught me how to fly it.
- That's pretty awesome.
- Yeah.
- What's the most romantic
thing that's happened to you?
- The most romantic thing.
It is hard 'cause...
I need shots for this.
I was engaged eight months
ago, so that thing, that ended,
you know, but I met her four years ago.
We were going to Catalina
Island, and we took a ferry,
and it was me, my brother,
and then this girl was
sitting with her friends,
you know, it was like
a bachelorette party.
And she was just sitting, you
know, right across from me,
and I caught her looking at me.
And I grew up in Boston and
Boston people are kinda forward.
So I look at her, I was like,
"What are you looking at?"
In a, I guess, fun way.
And she was like, "Oh, you
have, you know, nice skin."
I was like, "Oh, that's
creepy, but thank you.
"I appreciate that."
So she laugh, I laugh, and
then after the boat stopped,
we walked towards the island,
and it was very, like, platonic
conversation, you know,
and I get to know her a little bit.
And then in the end where it was like,
there was like two ways separating,
so she went with her friends
and then I went with my brother
and our friend, my friends,
and, you know, I told her like
it was really nice meet her
and hopefully, you know,
we'll come across again.
And a couple of time has passed,
and then I was with my brother,
we got another group
talking, and then I saw her,
and then I right away, ran up to her,
start talking to her.
And something told me
that I had to kiss her.
I was like, "Hey, I have to kiss you."
She's like, "What? Get
away from me, you creep."
In a fun way, I guess, right?
Like, "I'm sorry, I have to kiss you.
"Something's telling me."
So she's like, fine.
So I kiss her, it was like
a really good novella kiss.
You know what I mean?
Like, that good, the leg goes up.
After that, the whole trip, it
was just me and her flirting.
And then she went back
home to Philadelphia,
I went back to San Diego.
So she moved here, we started hanging out
and then one thing led to another
and then we started living together
and then I asked her to marry me,
you know, we were in Greece.
But the things with me is I
like to make people happy,
regardless of what I want.
Strangers, friends, family, just,
I don't care, just as
long as you're happy.
So the idea of marriage was her idea.
And then that idea became
kind of big in my mind now.
I was like, I don't know
if I wanna marry her,
which it sucks 'cause she's
like six years older than me.
- Oh, she's ready to settle.
- And then she's like,
"This is the ring I want."
I'm like, "Sure, absolutely."
And then something just hit like,
I don't know if I wanna marry her.
Which it sucks, which broke my heart,
because I felt like I wasted her time.
And I wanted to be with
her, but something happened.
Like why'd this happen?
You know what I mean?
Like, who's laughing at this?
It's not funny.
So, I still feel guilty, you know?
But, then I did the whole move out
and all the fun thing,
cry a lot, you know?
The youzsh.
- Well, I'm sorry that happened.
- I know.
Teachy moment.
What about you? Any fun, sad story?
- Fun, sad story.
I can't really think of
the last romantic thing
that's happened to me.
I'm very torn between
liking romance and not.
I feel like that I like the idea of it,
but when it's done to me,
it just doesn't feel very natural.
Maybe because it doesn't
come from the right person.
- Yeah.
- It's happened a couple of times,
but it just, it makes me uncomfortable,
because it's not from the person
I would want it to be from.
- Oh, I see.
Do you have somebody in mind?
And then why don't you
just ask him out and
- No, I don't.
- do your own romantic thing?
I mean, it's the 21st century, girl,
you know what I mean?
Well, let me ask you,
do guys come up to you
and start talking to you?
- Not a lot.
Maybe, I just don't come off too friendly.
- But guys still approach you, right?
Do you, in your mind, do you think like,
"Okay, here comes another creep"?
- I think it's more the environment.
It depends on where I'm at.
If I'm in a club, and
everyone's kind of drunk,
I'm just like, I don't really.
If it was like a, you know, a more...
- Supermarket.
- A supermarket or library, at a--
- Balboa Park, doing random interview.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Stuff like that.
- It'd be different.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- What do your hands say about you?
- My hands?
- Yeah (chuckles)
(Meredith giggles)
- Currently, I have a
gorgeous engagement ring.
- Oh, congratulations.
- Thank you.
He's the most incredible man ever.
I also, you can tell about me,
that, I don't know what you would call it,
brave or something, maybe?
I have some little hand tattoos.
One of them, it's a quote
on the side of my hand,
it says "Still I rise",
and I ended up getting it
because I've always loved
the poem from Maya Angelou.
But in symbolism with it
is that I'm a diabetic
and I've almost died like several times
for my sugars being too low.
And so, anytime I got to
that, I was able to rise.
So, still I rise.
My blood sugars and just
out of that state, you know?
In life.
- That's amazing.
- Thank you.
Something I wrote a while back,
now that I'm thinking about it,
it's, you can think of
hands in a different way,
you know, it's not just our physicalities,
it's, you can look at my hands
and know that I have
touched people who I love,
I have touched things that I've loved.
My hands have wrapped themselves around me
in the most needed times.
- Yeah.
- The list goes on, so.
Do you have any, like modifications or
anything?
- You know, not too many.
I don't have any tattoos.
I have my ears pierced,
just the regular way.
That's it, really.
- What's the most painful
thing you've been told?
- I don't know.
When I was young, my,
you know how dad can be?
Like, my father just, he got angry,
and I did something wrong,
and he said I'm not
gonna amount to anything,
you're worthless and all that.
If I fail, it just seems like
I'm not gonna amount to anything good.
You know what I mean?
I'm a failure.
So the thought is still there, sadly.
But once again, being
positive kinda helps, I guess.
But the idea of what he said
still kinda haunts me.
- Right.
- It's just hard.
- The most painful thing
someone's told me, I think,
is that they don't love me back.
I think that's one of
the most painful things
someone can ever tell you.
- Yeah.
- Especially when you love them very much.
- Are you talking about
family members or someone?
- In my case, this is a significant other.
- Okay.
- I asked if they loved me, so.
- Oh, and they were like,
beating around the bush.
- No, they said no.
- Oh.
- They said no.
And I asked a couple more times,
'cause I didn't believe that.
And again, it was a no.
- Yeah.
Like, how long have you been
going out to, like together?
- At the point, I was
with them for two years.
- Okay, at least it was in three years.
You know what I mean?
- Well, it extended for
six years after that.
- Oh.
On and off?
- Kind of.
- Yeah.
- Because I still didn't accept the fact
that they said no when I
asked if they loved me.
And you should believe
when someone tells you
that they don't love you.
- Absolutely.
You must really care for this person.
- I did, and I still kind of do.
- It just takes time.
'Cause I know how it feels,
like the love's still there and it's...
The love for my ex is still there.
I think it will always be there.
I think what are you gonna do?
We gotta move on, right?
How else we gonna move on with life.
You just gotta do what we gotta do.
You know, like, you gotta, you have to.
- Yeah.
- We just have to.
- Do you believe in God?
If yes, have you ever questioned God?
- I do believe in God.
I've had a lot of experiences
that have made me feel like
I know that God is there
and I know that He's real,
and I can wrestle with doubt,
but at the end of the day,
to invalidate those experiences
is to invalidate like the
foundation of my life.
- So, I've heard that
non-believers still go through
a near death experience,
and then all of a sudden
they're like, holy crap,
I was praying to God in that moment.
- Yeah.
- Is that how you started to believe
or were you brought up to believe it?
- It's always been something,
like a force in my life.
And I've always felt connected to it.
And I've had more and more
experiences over the years.
Like something that you're talking about,
I had a pretty bad ski accident
where I fell down the mountain,
like really fast and probably ultimately
should have broken a lot of bones or died.
I'm tumbling probably
50 or 60 miles an hour
down this mountain, uncontrollable,
and I yelled out loud, "Please God, stop!"
Or "Please God!"
And the minute I did that,
I was currently heading
towards one of those big poles
and I was probably gonna shatter my body,
and basically in that moment,
I stopped in the snow
right before that pole.
And,
I mean, some people can
say, "Oh, it's coincidence,"
or it was this or that.
And for me, that's where I
land is that God protected me.
- Okay.
- What about you?
- I believe God is art, and within us,
it's within other people.
It's not this white male with long hair.
- Yeah.
- I don't really believe in Jesus.
I never did.
I grew up Christian, but eventually,
my family stopped going.
- Do you believe in God?
If yes, have you ever questioned God?
- I don't know if I necessarily
believe in the biblical God.
I do believe in a higher power.
I don't know what it is or where it is,
but I know there's,
I believe there's something
bigger out there for us.
- Yeah, I get it.
- What about you?
- I do, I was grew up
Catholic, you know what I mean?
I mean, I have my own rules, you know,
if you're nice to people,
then I think you're doing all right.
You know what I mean?
So I guess that's what my faith is,
just as long as I'm nice to people,
you know, I'm thankful for what I have.
I just have faith, just try to find
some sort of miracle
in everyday, you know.
- All right, so what do
you think I look like?
- I mean, you told me that you
were goth in middle school,
so I have a feeling you
still like the color black?
I think you have darker hair.
We know you have tattoos and
piercings right now, right.
I think you have like hazel eyes.
- And Natalie, you have a powerful voice.
And that speaks a lot
about a person's character.
You have a lot of strength.
I feel like you're one of those people
that actually does show
up and is reliable.
Looks don't matter, but you're beautiful.
Thank you.
Like seriously.
Thanks for existing.
- I think you're a
really nice, kind person.
I guess the world really
needs that around here.
Easy to talk to.
Easy to befriend.
You know, honestly, I
cannot wait to turn around
and see who you are.
- Thank you.
- Beat that.
No, I'm kidding.
- Okay, I'm not very great at compliments.
I'm gonna try my best.
- Just make stuff up, I guess.
- No, I wanna be honest.
I think you're very easy to talk to.
I don't think we have a
lot of awkward pauses,
which is kind of rare.
At least for me.
You seem really relaxed as well.
You don't seem very tense and angry,
which is also rare to find.
- It's not everyday you
get to meet random people
and they actually have a conversation.
This way, we're made to talk.
You know what I mean?
Like we have to talk.
Maybe that's the way or just
walk back to back while talking to people.
That could be one thing.
- Are you Brazilian?
- I am Brazilian.
- Oh, nice.
- How do you know? You
have Brazilian friends?
Or are you Brazilian?
- I heard you say something about Brazil.
- And are you Latina?
- I am, I'm Mexican American.
- Okay, got it right.
But I never felt home in Brazil.
But then I moved to Boston.
I never felt home there.
Then I'm here, and I don't feel,
I mean, now my niece is born,
now I guess I have a reason, you know?
Yeah.
I know something, actually, I guess.
All right, good job, everybody.
All right, let's do this.
- Hi!
Can I hug you?
Oh, wait, COVID,
yeah.
- Yeah.
Do I look like what you thought?
- No.
- Not at all?
- Not at all.
- And where's your beautiful fiance at?
- I don't know where he went,
actually.
- [Natalie] He disappeared.
- I saw him walk off.
- I wanna know the big reveal now.
(both giggling)
- One, two, three.
Hi.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- Not too bad, not too
bad, hanging in there.
Okay, do you want my phone
number, just in case,
to talk about it.
- Sure, I'll take, yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Hey, everyone, Thoraya here.
I wanted to say thank you
for watching this episode.
I am still selling these
sweaters on my website
if you're interested.
I'll link it in my description.
I love you guys, and
I'll see you next week.
(exhilarating music)